hi I'm Jim Gaffigan and this is more me
doing questions from the internet would
you accept a million dollars to bump
that up for you let's say like oh would
you would you accept 10 million dollars
to be deported from the U.S you can
never come back
but you get to take one person with you
I'll let you take the kids I can take
all my kids all the kids and my wife no
she gets to stay she's like yeah
the family uh you know I not I mean I
love traveling internationally I love
different cultures but uh I and by the
way there's it's conversation that I had
with my wife but
um I don't know I don't think I want to
leave you know I mean I love Canada I
love Ireland what would be your number
one if you did leave
I don't know Europe everything's so
convenient living up to that right pale
right Canada and Ireland yeah people
like I go to the beach by the way it's
like Norway is pretty amazing too so I
don't know I love all and I love Asia
you know I mean not as much as you but
uh
but I uh I don't know I mean I don't
know but I'm very American yeah would
you rather fight a hundred duck-sized
horses or one horse-sized duck
I I think I'd rather fight uh
uh one horse-sized duck it's a big duck
man that's a big duck well but I mean
it's not like I'm just fighting I'd have
a tool wouldn't I no no all right so
what would you want to have oh yeah you
got a gun no yeah I guess I guess it
would be the 100 duck sized horses right
you just kick you do a lot of kicking
right but what tool are you gonna kill
this thing with by the way uh I would
say a machete okay okay yeah if I gave
you a machete the question changes or
like even if it was like a grim reaper
sickle
if a grim reaper sickle I would just cut
off all the legs
and then I would eat the duck then I
would I would eat the dot it'll be our
main family those ducks are cute this is
a big one here I was gonna say this is
the one for Jim Gaffigan you know bacon
or sausage first of all
I hope you got a lot of film in there
there are so many different things first
of all
there's different types of sausages
right and there is like Patty and
there's lengths and there's for the love
of God stop putting maple syrup on
sausage stop it
it's just not I mean first of all is
you know a whole maple syrup thing that
is just it's it's it's sugar spent all
right it's not it's just weird I love
Vermont I love Canada but like the maple
syrup pancakes no pancakes I do powdered
sugar and butter like an American
but like bacon if it's crispy but I
don't know I don't I feel like when they
deep fry it that's kind of cheating yeah
and then but wait so back to the first
thing sausage or links or Patty where do
you go I go Patty
it has to be Patty and the only links I
will eat are those little baby guys yeah
and but like it's kind of
and I love traveling internationally but
like we've all well you never know
there's there's links and then there's
sausages
you know it's like you have a hot dog in
another country and you're like this is
a hot dog yeah like what are you guys
doing here right but like the sausage
thing and like even you know the British
bangers it might be you know those are
good but like maybe no you know I mean
sometimes you're like I don't I don't
want to know it was an animal
like people like oh it's a natural caser
I'm like I don't need that
you know what I mean like I just want it
to taste good and then like don't miss
you know don't mix up oh there's apple
and cinnamon just sausage yeah yeah
right anyway it's important so is the
final answer sausage I think it might be
sausage he didn't say much about that
and you know I have a great affinity for
bacon but like I think sausage by the
way I'm a midwesterner I prefer sausage
on my pizza
over pepperoni dinner version of sausage
yeah you know I prefer I prefer sausage
over pepperoni too and that's not to say
that I don't love pepperoni but like I
think uh sausage also
is there's less variance in your sausage
right like bacon can be too fatty could
be undercooked then it can be too crispy
or falls apart yes your Patty's gonna be
like your Patty your Patty is a safer
bet and like and then some bacon you're
just like what is going on yeah it's
just like and then Canadians I love you
but like you're ham bacon whatever
you're doing with that ham go I'm
getting it yeah and then like you you
know the UK they're bacon you're like
what is going on is this what about uh
do you do like Steakhouse thick cut
bacon yeah that's good but like often
they'll put maple on there and I don't
want that I don't want maple on my
brussels sprouts I don't want maple on
my bacon I don't certainly don't want it
on my sausages we're going Savory We're
not gonna throw in the sweet you can add
Savory to something that's sweet like
chocolate you can add some salt I get
that salted caramel I get that don't
ruin a Savory with some sweet in there
anyway I feel like I just talked
basketball with LeBron yeah
and by the way can I also say
often in my stand-up or you know
generally in life all real against
something like hiking or grapefruit
juice and then
within two years I'll be like oh I like
hiking or I like now I get grapefruit
juice it's like well you drink
grapefruit juice and yeah I like you
know now I'm like you know I know I only
eat grapefruit juice when I'm staying in
a hotel I mean I only drink it like I
don't drink it at home but like it's
also good for it's it helps with poop
that's for the ladies
how much money would it take you to give
up your favorite food for the rest of
your life and what would what is the
food
it was probably at this point it changes
right it's a question of monogamy is
monogamy real yeah is there a true love
yes but like but if you're like 17
versus 34 like I'm 21 you know
um but like would uh I could see you
know like I love Chicago deep dish
sausage but
I could see I mean you know like I also
feel like if it's the punishment for
eating something like I like jalapenos
they don't like me no do you remain so
like as much as I enjoy spicy food I
can't handle it like I love a real spicy
Indian food but I can't you know like
I'm out you know I mean I love a
pastrami sandwich but I need like three
days to recover do you know what I mean
what's your favorite cortical fancy food
like
I always said like I was like I could
eat steak and potatoes for the rest of
my life potatoes yes I go to like a
steakhouse these days I used to you know
like we're going to Steakhouse tonight
now I'm like I think I might get like
the salmon I don't know really it's kind
of like I wish I liked salmon I'm just
too manly I I wish I like no I've you
know I remember my wife and I when we
were dating I went to Alaska we I did a
cruise a a cruise ship I don't want to
brag in Alaska and so we were there she
was like you gotta try salmon here or
not that you but you know and I just I
just don't like it and I wish I liked it
because you're a taste well it's
disgusting no also it's just oily and
you know I'm just I wish I liked it but
I don't what is the fiercest animals you
think you could take in a fight
wow you know like I mean you encounter
you think that you could take a lot of
animals but like
then when you're outside and you see a
skunk and you're like oh my God this guy
I'm so here I mean it's a raccoon is it
daytime I don't know yeah yeah I mean
the rabies I don't want 50 shots in my
tummy
but I don't know I
you know it's also different when you're
just outside walking outside yeah like
life or death I'm telling you this
animal is coming at you yeah defend your
kids oh yeah
there's an actress on the card there
yeah I think I probably I mean I would
probably get really beat up but I mean
if I'm protecting my children that's the
thing too not all of them
favorites I feel like I might you know
you might really yeah rip me to shreds
but I'm not gonna die unless you're like
right yeah again do you have a weapon do
you have a do you have a sickle I'll
give you a a club a club
yeah I think I could take down a wolf
I do I mean I would definitely you know
wolves are they're way bigger than you
people like oh it's like a dog it's like
no no no no they're huge they're huge
and they're they're strong and they can
jump and they got the
and they're great kissers
if you could put any franchise
restaurant in your house what would it
be ooh this is interesting you know it's
also like these I gotta be honest
this is totally not answering the
question
it's amazing when uh when a uh when you
break up with a restaurant like a friend
a place that you go to and you're like
this is my like I loved Chipotle I loved
it and then it just broke my heart and
it's not like some of it that some of it
the delivery was completely messed up
but some of it was cold and I was like
uh
and uh but usually you got a couple bad
experiences yeah yeah I think it was
like a couple bad experiences
but I you know
I would say
either mamoons uh which is not really a
chain it's a Falafel shawarma place it's
they have one in these Village in uh the
West Village
um because that would be kind of healthy
and you know you know eating hummus
you're you're not like you know you're
not doing a great thing with all that
bread but but uh but Shake Shack would
be pretty good Five Guys is pretty
amazing too Five Guys I would just I
would be dead right the
crinkle fries at Shake Shack I'm not a
fan of until you get the dipping cheese
and then I'm almost like forget about
the burger I just want the cheese fries
by the way the breakfast sandwich at
Shake Shack never
sausage patty sausage by the way
breakfast sandwich don't cut us a link
and make it no stop doing that
let's go back to sausages like kielbasa
how do you feel about kielbasa I feel
like it's too hard to bite into it's
very like it's like it's you know if you
feel like you you know that's sausage is
the gift that giveth and taketh you know
yeah it's like
but I do love a pierogi yeah I love a
pierogi love a pierogi love a pierogi
it's a very you know dynamic yeah you
know the best link sausage I think is
the Polish cabanasa you ever have one of
those it's like a snap sausage it's very
garlicky it's good it's good anyway you
are truly the master I am known as the
pig
I am somebody who eats way too much and
I've somehow figured out a way to get
paid for it which is great it's a
beautiful thing thank you for watching
answer the internet please subscribe to
the channel comment below on other
celebrities you'd like to see and make
sure you hit the Bell to get
notifications when new episodes come out